The Hunger Games did a lot of things right,
faithfully adapting Suzanne Collins' bestselling
books into a blockbuster franchise that launched
Jennifer Lawrence to worldwide superstar status.
But as good as it was, it didn't quite do
everything right.
Here's a look at some dumb things everyone
ignores about The Hunger Games.
Idiocracy
The basic concept of the Hunger Games takes
some suspension of disbelief to buy into,
but even then, the politics don't really make
much sense.
Think about this: the folks in the districts
do all the hard labor to keep the rich people
in the Capitol flush with food, and coal,
and amazing hair dyes.
Considering they need the workers in the districts
to keep working, wouldn't it make way more
sense to actually, y'know, feed them enough
to do that work?
Plus, given how technologically advanced the
Capitol is, using just a little bit of that
know how to help automate things like coal
mining would significantly boost productivity
while also raising quality of life and morale
in the districts.
Acting like a bunch of evil jerks might be
fun, but it just doesn't make good business
sense.
Drinking games
When we first meet Haymitch, he's pretty much
a useless, snarky drunk with no interest in
helping Katniss and Peeta figure out how to
survive when the fighting begins.
Then, the next morning, jerkface is gone and
has suddenly been replaced by a helpful, wise
mentor who whips the District 12 team into
shape.
That change happens literally overnight, so…
maybe all Haymitch needed that whole time
was a good breakfast?
Coaching fail
Speaking of Haymitch, he's apparently the
smartest dude in the entire country, because
when the games actually begin, the contestants
from every other district act like a bunch
of idiots.
Haymitch's big piece of advice is to ignore
the supplies at the cornucopia and just run
for the woods, because it's going to be a
bloodbath as the others fight over the goodies.
And it is!
It seems obvious, but apparently the mentors
in the other districts didn't think to pass
this nugget of wisdom along to their kids.
Because sure enough, a bunch of them get creamed
in the first thirty seconds.
Maybe their mentors were even drunker than
Haymitch?
Wait, no, that's impossible.
It's well after breakfast by this point.
Burn, baby, burn
A pivotal moment in the Hunger Games takes
place when Katniss is chased up a tree by
a pack of other contestants.
After a halfhearted effort to kill her, Peeta
convinces them to just make a campfire and
wait for her to die of, like, old age or something.
That turns out to be a bad plan, because through
a complete stroke of luck, Katniss finds a
conveniently placed hive full of genetically
modified bees, which she drops on their dumb
heads.
"I think those are tracker jackers.
Am I wrong?"
"Ohh… those things are very lethal."
"Mm.
Very."
But...if those kids can make fire, why didn't
they just, y'know, set fire to the tree?
Trees are made of wood, right?
Even in the future?
And if the flames didn't get her, the smoke
probably would have, or at least forced her
to jump — which probably would've hurt her
pretty bad.
Way to go, you dead dum-dums.
Cake wars
Peeta may not be the most useful guy with
a weapon, but he sure is one hell of a painter.
He shows off his incredible camouflage artistry
during training, and again uses it to go incognito
after suffering a pretty substantial sword
wound to the leg.
We're told he picked up this rare and impressive
skill by … decorating cakes at the District
12 bakery.
Really.
"I, uh, I used to decorate the cakes down
at the bakery."
"Oh…"
So does that mean that the US Military should
be tapping the camouflage skills of Duff "Ace
of Cakes" Goldman?
Should the Cake Boss be teaching courses to
army cadets at West Point about how to disguise
yourself as a giant, edible pink rose...for
combat reasons?
Just how the hell does baking and decorating
cakes teach a kid how to go full-on mud-man?
Listen, Peeta, we're calling shenanigans.
The amount of effort and talent it would take
to create that spotless camouflage is a whole
lot more than you'd pick up by writing "Happy
Birthday, Here's a Coal Cake" a few times
a week with an icing squirter.
Plus, since we're on the subject, how would
anyone in District 12, which is entirely made
up of starving coal miners have the cash to
get a cake?
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!